[Musique]
acquis banjo l'heure de pointe varie
tous les jours selon la marée
[Musique]
elle commande toute la vie du village et
l'armada des perroquets la respecte
rigoureusement
[Musique]
les hommes rejoignent leurs embarcations
harnachés de leur seule richesse
personnelle quelques flotteurs un filet
et une pagaie
wen
[Musique]
nous
nous sommes à l'embouchure de la rivière
bomba
le travail quotidien ce profil là bas à
l'horizon là où les eaux du fleuve se
marie avec celles de l'océan indien
[Musique]
qui banjo un village qui n'en est pas un
ou bien à peine absence sur la plupart
des cartes de la région
et pourtant cette saison plusieurs
centaines de personnes ont élu domicile
dans ces cabanes monté sur bois de
mangrove qui banjo vit au rythme de la
marée et s'assoupit lorsque les pêcheurs
l'ont désertée reste les femmes les
enfants et les commerçants devient
difficile d'être obligé de marcher dans
le beau conte la marée haute
tout remonte on n'est plus obligé de
travailler dans la boue mais le mieux
pour nous c'est quand ce n'est ni où ni
bas mis au milieu
[Musique]
l'eau douce elle arrive en pirogue par
le fleuve un bien précieux
même si ce n'est somme toute que de
l'eau un peu moins saumâtre qui si magna
bas l'eau d'ici et cher il nous faut de
l'eau propre
on va la chercher en amont dans la
rivière pour avoir de l'eau douce ça
cool là bas et on la récupère parce que
l'outil ci ne suffit pas à nos besoins
non
bon pendant ce temps là les pêcheurs ont
entamé leur journée
allons voir si la chance leur a souri
depuis deux heures déjà
mozilla et souleymane jette sans cesse
leurs filets avant de les laisser
dériver
et puis et puis ils doivent patienter
ici c'est comme attendre et mots on ne
sait jamais si ça viendra ou pas on a
mis le filet à louer maintenant on
attend on attend pour voir s'il a des
poissons ou pas les poissons ça marche
il n'y a pas de poisson remontée filet
et on va essayer un autre endroit
jamais très loin de cette pirogue voici
djerra fille et hussein
originaire de la même ville que leurs
copains m'ont euros à 10 heures de
marche à l'intérieur des terres eux sont
tombés plus vite sur un bon filon il y a
bien quelques poissons mais ce ne sont
pas eux qui sont recherchés en cette
saison les crevettes
c'est comme si c'était le territoire des
crevettes il y en a tout le temps ici
c'est notre coin préféré boivent
se déplacent ont attiré par l'eau on y
vient du delta de la rose hill ce sont
la boue et les algues qui attire les
crevettes
car c'est avec cela à ta place de
nourrices kamba en dialecte prendre en
anglais et en français on ne sait
comment les appeler crevettes ou
bouquets ou gambas selon la taille
si toutes ces petites pirogues viennent
envahir le delta c'est aussi parce que
les chalutiers n'ont pas le droit de
travailler durant la période de
reproduction
de décembre à avril alors les pêcheurs
artisanaux venus de toute la côte
tanzanienne convergent à la sortie de
l'estuaire où 80% des gambas sauvages du
pays qui sont attrapés le delta de la
rivière rufiji le plus large de tous les
staffs ricains et entre ses bras
erratique qui serpente à l'infini la
plus grande forêt de mangrove un espace
vierge une zone de frais pour les
crevettes mais aussi pour les poissons
est un havre de paix pour tous les
animaux sauvages
[Musique]
quant aux hommes ils s'échinent pas
attraper les crustacés et tous les
moyens sont bons
[Applaudissements]
la plus éreintantes de toutes les
techniques consistent à près de le filer
dans la mer
quand le niveau de l'eau le permet une
sorte de mini chalutage à pied la
difficulté au mot c'est que normalement
quand on pêche
on marche dans le sable et là on doit
marcher dans la main et parfois on
s'enfonce très profondément c'est ça la
difficulté est parfois quand on voit
qu'il ya des crevettes
on est obligé d'aller dans l'eau même si
elles nous arrivent jusqu'au cou tout
vient à point à qui sait attendre
à la mi-journée homogène à et souleymane
sarr qu'ils ne vont pas rentrer
bredouille pas beaucoup plus riches non
plus deux ou trois kilos 2 ou 3 euros
pour la journée
il y en a beaucoup je suis très content
car ça représente de l'argent il y en a
vraiment beaucoup on a même du mal à les
retirer de l'eau dans ma vie
[Musique]
la fin de la pêche elle dépend de la
marée évidemment
quand le courant fort si les fragiles
pirogue et les maigres filet perdre leur
utilité
[Musique]
alors retour à la voile ou ce qu'il en
reste
[Musique]
et voilà la deuxième heure de pointe
acquis banjo tous ceux qui étaient
restés à terre envahissent la plage à
sécher
[Musique]
en cette saison le petit hameau et ses
crevettes attirent à eux des migrants de
tous horizons
délaissant leur vie habituel venu
chercher de quoi nourrir leur famille
[Musique]
les huit autres mois de l'année les
quatre pêcheurs de moreau par exemple
n'ont guère d'autres moyens de
subsistance et à l'image du sen la
dérision comme moyen de résistance mon
travail principal c'est la pêche quand
je rentre au village je vais me reposer
avant tu ne vas pas cultiver les champs
je ne peux pas gérer ici pour le travail
quand je retourne dans mon village et
que je me repose et vous savez que j'ai
une femme alors il faut que je rentre
pour m'occuper d'elle youssouf non plus
n'habite pas en permanence acquis banjo
il n'exerce pas le métier de pêcheur
mais celui de commerce en négociant
crevettes son oeil avisé commence par
trier
car bananas tigré royal n'ont ni la même
taille ni la même valeur et la royale
souvent au meilleur prix la tigres se
vendent moins cher et la bonne anna
encore moins cher ça c'est un exemple de
la team la royale on l'appelle aussi
djombo
faire commerce de la crevette acquis
banjo n'est pas une sinécure
il faut loger sur place une bonne partie
de la saison et surtout composer avec
des installations rudimentaires et la
poya peau problème surtout pour la glace
c'est difficile de la trouver ici je
dois prendre la glace à dar es salaam
puis la mettre dans un bateau l'amener
ici c'est vraiment très difficile
les crevettes de yusuf
elles vont faire le voyage à rebours
puisqu'elles sont destinés aux
restaurants de la capitale et des zones
touristiques du pays
la fcd
j'habite à dar el salam lyndine là bas
c'est la vie la lire ici la campagne et
en ville il ya beaucoup de possibilités
pour vivre le niveau d'une beaucoup plus
de la moitié ont dit que la ville se
mieux qui s'est dit mais non ce grâce à
ce qu'on gagne ici les candidats rinaldi
qui banjo envahi par la crevette quatre
mois durant
mais est ce seulement un village
non plutôt un camp de pêche
placée très haut sur l'échelle du
dénuement même au regard de la très
pauvre tanzanie acquis banjo il n'y a
rien pas d'électricité pas d'eau
courante
évidemment
pas de service médical pas d'école pas
même une seule poubelle pour plusieurs
centaines d'habitants les maisons de
guingois sont alignés traces en trois ou
quatre semblant de rues au fil du temps
les habitants ont accumulé des rondins
de bois sur le sol pour éviter de
marcher dans la boucle
ainsi il est bien représentant de l'état
qui s'occupe de petits banjo de temps en
temps ramiz bongo et le maire de mme
sala le bourg dont dépend le camp de
pêche
après deux heures de pirogue
ce jeune agriculteur vient visiter comme
toutes les semaines le hameau du bout du
fleuve ou un de ses adjoints vite en
permanence est souvent la même
préoccupation apparaît au cours des
réunions
comment récolter les taxes sur les
revenus de la crevette aucun registre
n'est tenu sur les allées et venues des
pêcheurs et des commerçants la pêche bat
son plein et les gens gagnent bien leur
vie
mais on a une grande difficulté pour
amener des revenus au village on prend
pas les impôts systématiquement on
demande aux gens et s'ils peuvent ils
nous donnent
on est le problème c'est que peu
d'habitants de de retour de leurs marais
hussein et les autres pêcheurs de morrow
tente d'améliorer l'ordinaire acquis
banjo ils n'ont pas vraiment de chez eux
tout le monde doit vivre dehors et
partager une de ses grandes barak
loin de la famille
aujourd'hui ils fabriquent des filets
pour un acheteur un peu sourcilleux
vous croyez que je vais vous payez vous
avez commandé combien de pièces
6 alors il faut payer 2000 schilling
[Musique]
voilà l'endroit où je dors je dors ici
quand je travaille voilà c'est chez moi
le matin je sors je prends monte à côté
et je vais à la plage et vous dormez
comment pour faire un matelas j'utilise
des feuilles de palmier que j'arrange
bien des feuilles comme seignalet les
unes sur les autres
des femmes aussi vivaki banjo dans ces
conditions elles tiennent les
innombrables gargotes du village
certaines accompagnent leurs maris
d'autres viennent toutes seules pour la
saison comme bindi originaire de l'île
de mafia dépend beaucoup des pêcheurs
quand ils rentrent de la pêche
ils viennent manger ici à mafia il ya un
hôpital mais ici il ya juste de quoi
faire un peu de business
il n'y a pas d'hopital il n'y a rien pas
d'hôpital pas d'école les saisonniers
évident de venir avec leurs enfants
autant que faire se peut mais déjà les
quatre mois d'exil forcé perdu dans la
mangrove reste une épreuve pour
souleymane et tous les pêcheurs
[Musique]
on est habitués nous entendre on y ait
quelqu'un qui vient d'ailleurs ne peut
pas comprendre tu vois d'ailleurs des
endroits comme ça c'est bon pour les
animaux mais nous on vit ici et un autre
travail on peut pas vivre comme ça tu
peux même pas construit une vraie maison
dans ces conditions locales des audi n'a
pas de famille tient des retardataires
ils reviennent en fin de journée et ne
le regrette pas une pirogue rempli de
gambas plus grosse que la main ces
hommes ont connu un jour de chance le
rêve de tout pêcheur
voilà pourquoi chaque année comme une
ruée vers l'or ils viennent par
centaines
passée la saison dans le delta
aujourd'hui je suis content on a bien
pêcher aujourd'hui c'est mieux que les
jours précédents
cela se vend me schilling la pièce mille
shillings pour une grosse vous avez
gagné combien alors je suis pas sur mais
bon y en a peut-être une centaine
traduction plus de 60 euros pour maoulid
saïd environ le salaire mensuel minimum
du pays
et
[Musique]
et une heure plus tard les prisons déjà
quitté le continent
chaque soir un ou plusieurs bateaux à
moteur emmène la délicate marchandises
vers sa destination ultime l'europe
mais il faudra d'abord passer par
l'étape mafia une petite île à deux
heures de mer du delta mafia le royaume
des doses ces gros bouteraa voile
parfois assisté d'un moteur tout ce
temps venus de la péninsule arabique
qu'il y à quelques siècles
ici les passagers mais aussi les
marchandises de la vie courante embarque
encore à bord de ces bateaux du temps
jadis
c'est bien joli mais nous ne sommes pas
là pour ça mais pour filmer l'usiné de
congélation temps pesca dès notre
arrivée les bidons sont évacués tout est
nettoyé à grande eau
et surtout surtout interdiction formelle
de laisser une caméra pénétrer à
l'intérieur du bâtiment temps pesca n'a
pourtant rien à se reprocher sur le plan
sanitaire et satisfait aux normes
européennes selon tous ceux qui ont pu
visiter l'usiné
genre un peu tout ça là ça va là ok
toujours est il que monsieur raoult le
manager indien consent juste à nous
présenter ses produits finis secret de
fabrication ou méfiance vis-à-vis des
documentaires occidentaux mystère nous
n'en serons pas plus sur le traitement
des crevettes -qui banjo oui c'est un
très bon produit nous avons une très
bonne image de marque sur le marché
international ok combien de tonnes de
crevettes vous traiter chaque année
pendant la saison
oui nous faisons des crevettes de bonne
qualité pour approvisionner le marché à
l'exportation
cette usine appartient à un groupe
international qui dès l'an prochain
produira des crevettes d'aquaculture sur
l'île de mafia pour éviter les
incertitudes de l'approvisionnement en
mer notamment par l'épaisseur du delta
aujourd'hui des acheteurs sud africain
et italiens viennent faire une visite
express à l' usine
pour leurs clients crevettes sauvages ou
d'élevage sont difficiles à reconnaître
au goût seul le prix fait la différence
mais les gambas géantes ont encore de
l'avenir
car jamais l'aquaculture ne prendra le
temps de les regarder pousser pendant
cinq ou six ans oui si vous prenez en
compte tous les éléments la propreté de
l'eau la taille le cas lebron
vous avez une meilleure qualité et une
crevette plus grande que dans une ferme
où vous ne produisez qu'une certaine
taille
ce n'est pas économiquement viable de
les faire grossir autant que dans la
nature donc oui la tanzanie assurément
offre une très belle opportunité pour
les crevettes sauvages
[Musique]
nous revoilà chez les oubliés du delta
danio gaillac à youssouf a rejoint la
cabine téléphonique du moins le seul
arbre sous lequel il est possible de
passer une communication qui banjo
n'échappe pas entièrement à la modernité
s'appelle tony street la rue des villes
mixtes car les gens qui habitent ici
viennent d'un peu partout mafia dar el
salam wire donc on l'appelle le tennis
il ya des magasins des grands magasins
de télévision et même le cinéma les
boutiques à l'instar des habitants sont
temporaires
chaque jour les commerçants espèrent que
quelques coups de fil et miraculeux
rendront les pêcheurs peu regardants à
la dépense
t-shirt habits d'enfants les étalages ne
rappelle en rien l'abondance des grandes
villes et les achats les plus fréquents
sont ceux de cigarettes à l'unité
abdel rahmane le vendeur tient un
magasin six mois dans le village voisin
et déménage tout son stock pour la
saison des crevettes à la principale
difficulté c'est le capital de départ
si j'avais un bon capital pourrait
vendre une grande quantité de choses du
riz des haricots pour les vêtements
j'aimerais aussi aller d'autres hostiles
qui sont un peu plus chers mais comme je
n'ai pas d'argent en avance je suis
limité outre tony street
il existe aussi une entame en street
autrement dit la rue des divertissements
[Musique]
deux baraquements aménagé pour
accueillir des spectateurs de midi à
minuit sans interruption un groupe
électrogène pour la télé et ambiance
viril assuré sur l'écran
[Musique]
et au fond de la salle puisqu'il ne faut
pas oublier que nous sommes à crevettes
landes une glacière remplie de crustacés
[Musique]
m
aurel
le
à
quelques jours par mois les détritus ce2
qui banjo sont importés au loin grâce
aux grandes marées purificatrice
et
voilà donc pourquoi toutes les baraques
sont montés sur des échasses
[Musique]
car parfois le village quitte le monde
terrestre
[Musique]
il
c'est un village d'eau on peut comparer
cela à une île dans le delta
c'est un village flottant sur l'eau mais
c'est l'eau qui vient et qui repart et
quand l'on vient le village devient
flottant et quand l'eau s'en va le
village vous devient sec
[Musique]
fataliste par la force des choses les
gens disent y trouve encore des
avantages à cette montée des eaux
[Musique]
désormais les bateaux peuvent accoster
directement dans les maisons sans effort
les inconvénients presque impossible
désormais de cheminée dans la rue à
moins de se transformer en acrobates
[Musique]
auj
en vous l'avez dit depuis le début qu'il
banjo c'est à peine un village est ici
la seule autorité c'est la marée
ah ah
[Musique]